[Music]
i'm peter tatchell
welcome to this session how to right
wrongs
i think it's a good place to start is to
remind ourselves that until
1999 britain had by volume
the largest number of anti-gay laws of
any country in the world some of them
dating back centuries by 2013
um those laws all the major anti-gay
laws
had been repealed now that is
an astonishing achievement in that short
space of time
all these historic anti-gay laws or at
least all the major ones
were repealed and of course the
culmination was
the legislation of equal marriage in
2000 2013.
um if we look at how that was achieved
it was through a combination of both
external outsider protest and direct
action by
groups like outrage and then also
by insider parliamentary lobbying
and legal cases bought by
stonewall those two tactics
worked in tandem a bit like the
suffragettes
and the suffragettes both were needed
both were necessary um
if we look at the outrage campaigns for
example
around the age of consent outrage
organized teenage kissings and turnings
where young people below the lawful age
of this consent
for gay and bisexual men um
stage kissings and confessed to having
same-sex relations uh contrary to the
law
effectively challenging the police to
arrest them
um and then as a result of those
protests
there was a huge amount of media
coverage and on top of that
uh of course it generated a huge public
debate
and that raised public awareness and put
the authorities under pressure
to change and then off the back of that
stonewall lobbied members of parliament
and the government
and indeed bought legal cases in
the british and european courts so that
eventually
finally the combination of those two
tactics
resulted in the law being changed
and the age of consent be equalized at
16
for everyone in 2001
[Music]
having said all that there are still
inequalities today
you know we have made enormous progress
but there are still
some i suppose compared to the past
relatively minor
uh inequalities in the law
uh when it comes to blood donations for
example
uh gay and bisexual men are still
not allowed to donate blood
if they've had sex with a person of the
same sex
in the preceding three months
now that is based on a stereotypical
generalization about
same-sex behavior the idea or the
thinking behind this is that gay and
bisexual men
are at higher risk of hiv and other
sexual infections but of course some
are and they should not donate blood
but others are not others are in
long-term monogamous relationships
they've tested hiv negative there's no
reason
why they shouldn't give love so
the push really now is to move from this
three-month deferral period to a policy
of
individual assessment where each
individual regardless of their sexuality
or gender identity
is required to answer more detailed
questions about their sexual behavior
to establish their risk factors so what
we're saying is
test the blood not the sexuality
another outstanding issue is the fact
that
all the equality laws fantastic that
they are
have some limited qualified exemptions
for religious organizations not just
place of worship but also faith-run
schools
hospitals nursing homes
shelters of the homeless and so on in
certain circumstances
they are permitted to discriminate
against lgbt bus people either in
their employment policy or in the
provision of services if they can
establish a case that it is necessary
to maintain their religious ethos
now no other institution in our society
has such exemptions this is
completely and totally unique and
my view is that religious organizations
should not be above the law but they
should be required to conform
to the equality statutes in the same way
as everyone else we also have the
problem
that the gender recognition act which
was pioneering
progressive in 2004 is now
outdated um it has
far too many hurdles and obstacles to
trans people getting a legal change
in their affirmed gender
the government did promise reform under
theresa may
but that has effectively been kicked
into long grass
under boris johnson so it still
is an issue for trans people um
they don't want to understandably to
have to go through all these
medical hoops and hurdles to be able to
affirm
their gender identity in legal documents
we also have the ongoing issue of
the difficulty of lgbt plus refugees
seeking asylum and securing it
the rate of refusal for lgbt plus
refugees
is much higher than for political
religious or ethnic refugees and a lot
of it boils down to the fact of the
difficulty
of establishing or proving one sexuality
or gender identity but even where that
can be proven through
documents and personal affidavits from
people who know the person
who's seeking asylum still the rate of
refusal is
very very very high and this is really
heartbreaking because
some lgbt refugees who fled
serious persecution where they're at
risk of imprisonment
or even execution are sometimes sent
back
to those countries where their lives and
liberty
is in danger so the asylum system
doesn't need reform and i might add not
just
for lgbt plus refugees but for all
refugees
because currently it is biased and
weighted against
genuine applicants and the final child
raise is
of course we have same-sex marriage but
it is
not true marriage equality because it is
under a separate law
the 19 the 2013 law
rather than under the main marriage law
the 1949 marriage act
so having a separate law
is not equality and moreover
there is a lock in place in this law
which prevents the church of england
from conducting
same-sex marriages even if it wishes to
so even if the church of england decided
that it would agree
to conduct same-sex marriages in its
place of worship
the law prohibits the church from doing
that
and that is an attack upon religious
freedom
as well as discrimination
so these are some ongoing wrongs
that need to be put right looking at the
overall issue i think we
have made some progress after a big
campaign
nearly a decade ago or about a decade
ago
the government did issue a public
apology
to gay bisexual men for the historic
persecution they had faced under
anti-gay laws
that was a really big important step
um and then a bit later
again under pressure from campaigners
like myself and many others
the government agreed to introduce a
parliament system
to pardon men who had been
convicted under these laws now
the problem is that the way the pardon
scheme is working
is not effective and not
fair um the last figures that i
saw showed that about two-thirds
of men who applied for a pardon
had been refused now it's true the
pardon scheme
does only apply to men who are convicted
for behavior that is no longer a crime
today
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas